[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
so the beats X are brand new there are
now the cheapest wireless beats that you
can buy and even cheaper than the
earpods now and they supposedly actually
sound better too so that means they're
definitely worth the money right well
let's break that down so the beats X are
another new pair of wireless bluetooth
buds for 2017 it's 2 in earbuds
connected by a wire with an inline
battery and a bunch of little controls
and tricks and features that make them
work so in that way the beats X compare
really well to some other wireless audio
options we've gotten recently like the
jaybird x2 and x3 and of course the air
pods in fact I'd say the beats X are
pretty much a hybrid exactly in between
those two the beats have a little bit of
a different shape and a different
functional layout but obviously they're
still pretty recognizable with the logo
and everything as beats to anyone
looking for them now wireless earbuds
have a bunch of different ways of
sitting slash cable management you know
some are retractable some have some sort
of a wire clip like the Jaybirds some
have no wires at all these beats have no
cable management at all except for the
magnet in the head of each earbud which
turns out to be just enough I think the
wires a little bit longer obviously and
it's meant to basically sit on your neck
which isn't too bad and you can barely
feel it and then when you're not
listening to them anymore you can take
them out of your ears
and basically clip them together and
then that makes this sort of a beats
necklace so I guess if you thought beats
were out of the fashion game they're
totally not but you still have all the
functionality of a normal pair of
headphones which is good you have the
inline control so your song forward and
backward you have the volume up and down
a play/pause button and even an inline
microphone for using phone calls but
since it's now 2017 they're also now
completely wireless and also use Apple's
new super low powered super awesome w1
chip so same thing as the air pods you
power them on and your iPhone
immediately recognizes them and pairs
them to that and every other Apple
device you have but also unlike the air
pods you can connect these to an Android
phone via bluetooth no problem and they
keep all of their functionality you can
connect air pods to an Android phone if
you want but if you do you lose like all
the cool features and functions like you
lose the play/pause when you take it out
you
you lose Siri you lose volume control it
just like a very basic headset at that
point but if you connect beats X to an
Android phone you still have the
physical inline controls here so you
still have volume you still have a
microphone it all still works so inline
controls are good but there are some
downsides of these headphones too
durability wise these aren't sweat proof
or water resistant at all like in anyway
now I haven't had any problems with mine
and I haven't heard about any problems
yet but it's kind of weird that they're
lacking even those basic protection
pretty much just don't take these out in
the rain or if you workout and you sweat
a lot then you can't use these for
working out either which it wasn't that
kind of the point of wireless headphones
like this it seems like a glaring
omission but people smarter than me will
tell you that that's just so beats can
point you towards another pair of
headphones they sell just for working
out so okay if you're not using them for
working out then you're just you know
you're walking the dog walking to class
just very casual use around how do they
do with that well first of all they
sound pretty decent they sound like a
lot of other premium Bluetooth earbuds
which isn't a super high bar to clear
but they're not garbage at all they
definitely are a lot heavier and on the
base your side for sure their beats but
that's fine for a lot of people volume
is good and they manage to make a really
good seal in my ear even better than the
jaybird X 3s thanks to the wing tip so
the seal makes the noise isolation that
it creates really really good at least
with my ear shape it's excellent I know
some people can just like put air pods
in their ear and run around no problem
they don't fall out I'm not one of those
people my ears don't work with that so
having the wing tip like the X 3s really
works well with the beats X stage my ear
seals really well the little wire around
your neck line your first wearing them
is a little annoying at first especially
since they have these little batteries
in line as well but it was really easy
to get used to now I can never quite
forget it was in my ear like the
Jaybirds which go around the back of
your neck but beats do still get points
for comfort here and then the battery
life is pretty solid you're looking at
about six to eight hours tops of charge
but then they also have this awesome
quick charging if you pick them up and
they're dead you can plug them in for
five minutes and add two hours of
listening time which is dope and they
charge via this lightning cable so no
dock or pouch or cradle needed just
literally plug them directly in with the
same cable you charge your iPhone with
and you're good to go
so this is
obviously further reinforcement that
this is made for iPhone users first if
you're an Android phone person you have
a USB cable so you need to carry two
different chargers one for headphones
one for your phone not really meant to
do that it's made for the iPhone and of
course they are portable too that's like
a big point so they come with this case
that looks like a mouth and you can just
crumple them up and shove them in to
this case it's not very clean it's not
super elegant I just ended up shoving
them in a sweatshirt pocket or in my
backpack more often than not but yeah
they're definitely still portable so has
150 bucks as a total package are the
beats X the best beats ever sure yeah
I'd give it that I'd say evany at least
in the bang for the buck category and
the bang for the buck for Beats category
yeah these are pretty good but that
doesn't means you get him like you got
to know who-who beats are made for
people who want beats people who worked
out with their headphones who are really
active sweat a lot do fitness sports
activities they'll want like sweat proof
headphones they'll find stuff like the
j-bird x3 much better but if you just
want like no wires at all you want
totally Wireless then they'll spring for
something like the air pods but people
who want beats can now justify getting
these beats thanks for watching talk to
you guys in the next one peace
[Music]